[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to the third
episode of ask google cloud it's the
show where we answer the most pressing
question facing humanity
is it gif
or is it jif
okay actually on second thought it's
probably better that we don't start a
war in the comments section so let's
just stick with cloud topics i'm
stephanie wong a cloud developer
advocate and today i'm joined by fellow
developer advocates seth vargo
and carter morgan today we are answering
questions submitted by you our fantastic
google cloud youtube and social media
audience post your questions in the
comments with hashtag askgooglecloud and
they might be featured on a future
episode
and if you have other questions that
come up as you're watching today please
go ahead and type them in the live chat
and we'll do our best to try and get to
all of them
we are going to be hosting ask google
cloud segments throughout the year so be
sure to subscribe to the channel to get
notified every time a new episode comes
out
alright so with that said let's get
started with today's topic security
all right so our first question of the
day comes from christianity m who asks
does two
authentication fully protect us
so seth we'll start with you for this
one i know you have a lot of background
in this area
awesome uh thanks stephanie and thanks
krishnadev for the question so
what you have to think about when you
think about mfa which is multi-factor
authentication or 2fa which is
two-factor authentication is defense in
depth uh we know that a username is kind
of public information a password is
something private and then multi-factor
auth or two-factor auth is something
else that an attacker would need to
compromise in order to gain access to
your account
if you ever see a question like is
something 100 secure or does this fully
protect us the answer is always no
nothing is 100 percent secure nothing is
a hundred percent preventative
but it's all about defense and depth we
like to talk about layers of an onion
um when we talk about security but i
actually like to talk about security in
terms of medieval times see the thing is
we didn't really invent defense in depth
in the computer security space
um if you think about a castle
most people most people are familiar
with a moat right you surround the
castle with a moat and a drawbridge and
you put scary alligators in the moat and
then people have to cross that moat to
get to the castle
but if that's all an attacker had to do
they could just swim really fast and go
get the prince princess king queen
whatever
uh actually if we look at the way that
castles were designed and architected
during medieval times they practiced
defense and depth it wasn't just a moat
but the actual architecture of the
castle was designed such that the prince
princess king queen were maximally
protected
just as an example the
stairways in medieval castles were
designed such that they would curve up
and to the right and this was primarily
so that the defender the people
defending the castle had an advantage
they had a height advantage since they
would be coming down the stairs and
since most people were predominantly
right-handed during that era they had a
swing advantage they were swinging at a
downward angle gravity giving them favor
and with their dominant hand when you
compare this to the attacker who is
swinging at a backswing up a hill on an
incline they have a disadvantage so this
idea of defense and depth is really not
a new concept it's existed for hundreds
of thousands of years we're just
applying it so
nothing's 100 secure but that doesn't
mean you still shouldn't do it you
should definitely adopt multi-factor
authentication or two-factor
authentication if your upstream account
provider supports it
yeah i'm surprised we don't have a
curved stairways in our data centers at
least not that i've seen but you know
maybe maybe we will but it's cool how we
translate those concepts into our
logical security too and uh one way that
i know our security specialists here
think of it is to explain 2fa as
something you know and something you
have right so something you know like
the password or the pin number and then
something you have like your phone token
or other digital device and then the
other thing is something you are so
something unique to your physical being
like biometrics or fingerprints palm
prints retina scans gps location i know
that i went through that at the data
center which we'll talk about in a
little bit but yeah it's all an extra
layer of protection like you said
all right so moving on to our second
question
so we have a question from alessandro c
who asks how can we secure a google
cloud storage bucket in which we store
sensitive client csvs are there any best
practices to consider
so seth can you go ahead and answer this
one for us too
yeah this is also a great question that
really leads into a discussion around
threat modeling
what are you trying to protect against
what are the attack vectors that you're
trying to protect against in case of
google cloud storage you can enforce
acls or ackles access control lists on
individual objects within a cloud
storage bucket and you can govern those
with identity and access management or
iam
so you can ensure that only customer a
has access to object a and customer b
only has access to csv b
now you can also add additional controls
on top of that on top of identity and
access management such as vpc service
controls where you can define a service
perimeter around a cloud storage bucket
or other google cloud resources so that
they're not accessible outside of
authorized networks or outside of other
projects that you've pre-configured so
really there is no
you know checklist box and your cloud
storage bucket is now magically secure
you need to think about your threat
model what you're protecting against
what are the access patterns
and how can you most restrict those
resources to only be accessed by the
customers when they need to access it
from where they need to access it
yeah i think vpc service controls are
great as you said you define fine grain
perimeter controls that enforce your
security posture across your google
cloud services i've used it with
bigquery
and cloud storage and it helps really
with data exfiltration um and then
i think you might have talked a little
bit about context aware
access as well is that similar to
identity aware uh proxy
so it's a little bit different so
context or access is like
given my current context which could be
like my device my mobile phone my laptop
or perhaps my location my network do i
have permission to access this resource
so even though i am seth
can seth access this resource in this
context right maybe i can only access it
when i'm at home on my home network but
i can't access it if i'm at a hotel on
an untrusted network
identity aware proxy is a google cloud
product that you can put in front of one
of your applications and resources
that let you enforce these types of
policies so that you don't have to
modify your code so it sits in front of
your code so you can apply these
policies so you don't have to modify
your own code in order to enforce some
of these policies so they're related but
slightly different got it got it so
identity aware proxy in front of your
sensitive app it's like if you want to
grant access to all employees if they're
from a trusted corporate device versus
granting access to employees in like a
privileged access group if the url path
starts with something like forward slash
admin okay so moving on to question
number three the next question is from
dilla bexs who asks
how do you check if there are any
security breaches in the cloud
carter let's go to you for this one
oh thank you stephanie and dylan texas
and uh
really this comes down to two things in
my opinion uh one which i'm assuming is
kind of taken care of but you know maybe
you shouldn't assume but having policies
in place to say who should be able to
access what and when and seth was kind
of touching on that before when he said
there's context and there's things like
iam to say which roles can access this
safely and fine so if you've set that up
that's the first step because then you
can do things like have logging set up
to say
what people accessed accounts when at
what time uh and then you can start to
make decisions based on these activities
so if people are accessing information
at a really really late point in time
you might say that's suspicious let's
look into this more but that again
starts with having some policies set up
in place to say who should be able to
access what when
um
yeah and then i think another thing
that's really useful is having
basically a hub where you can find this
information pretty easily and so these
are things google cloud kind of provides
that i like but i i think those are the
the first steps to finding out about
security breaches
yeah and i think one of those hubs for
example is is our security command
center right and i i've seen it evolve
over the past few years and they've done
a really great job at designing
dashboards like security health
analytics where you can see at a glance
the number of projects you have what
resources are deployed and then manage
which service accounts have been added
or removed and then it actually even
gives you actionable recommendations
when it surfaces any misconfigurations
or miss
compliance violations
um and has some more advanced features
too like detecting threats um for common
container attacks and we actually have a
series so i'm going to plug that here
because i worked on it but it's called
getting started with uh security command
center so go ahead and check that out
and uh it's in our youtube channel
so thank you carter we're going to move
on to our next question which uh and
it's from dhiraj p who asks are service
accounts in some way related to access
scopes so carter do you have any
thoughts on this
i have some thoughts i actually want to
know more about like what access scopes
are because off top my head i don't know
what that is i might have to defer
um
but when i think about service accounts
the first thing i think about is
automated access you know um so instead
of having a person manually log into
everything what if i have an application
or a script that can log in and run
things update something for me
and then when i think about that that
automation it's like well how do i do
this in a way that's safe or secure you
know i don't want to have to like take
my personal password and just write it
down somewhere that a script can look at
because then it's very unsafe and so
service accounts solve that
but when it comes into the access scopes
i'm actually like like uh if steph or
stephanie or seth have uh more context
there i would love to hear it because i
want to know about that too
yeah i can i can definitely chime in so
you have to kind of forget about google
cloud for a second because access scopes
actually come from oauth um which is the
authentication mechanism by which you
authenticate to google cloud but it's an
open standard it's also how you kind of
like sign in with github sign in with
twitter etc and oauth the standard
defines access scopes as the access
control so for example
let's say you're giving someone access
to your twitter account when you do that
you're authorizing actions that they can
take on your behalf so you may grant
someone read-only access they can only
read your tweets and your direct
messages uh but you could also grant
them the ability to tweet on your behalf
you might do this when you sign in with
uh like a tweet bot or some third party
application
those those permissions actually map to
what we call oauth scopes
which we call access scopes on google
cloud
so when google cloud was you know first
getting created or even before google
cloud when there were just google
developer apis we relied on access
scopes as basically identity and access
management so in order to control
whether or not you had permission to
read from a cloud storage bucket versus
writing to a cloud storage bucket you
had different access scopes
but there's some limitations in the
specification i won't go into a lot of
detail but we've since evolved google
cloud platform to have a really really
rigorous identity and access management
system
so in general when you're interacting
with google cloud we recommend that you
grant the cloud platform oauth scope
to the account that's being authorized
and then you leverage identity and
access management to give really
fine-grained roles and permissions that
follow the principle of least privilege
got it got it and
if i recall correctly i think there
might be a case where if you're using a
default service account it still has
access scopes without iam is that is
that true
yeah so if you're running on google
compute engine or google kubernetes
engine there is a default service
account
that has some
pretty restrictive access soaps so when
you actually provision a virtual machine
or a kubernetes cluster you get to pick
do you want access to all cloud apis the
default apis or none which is is no
scopes and
in general like you should probably
click the box that says all apis and
then use identity and access management
instead to practice the principle of
least privilege
but for backwards compatibility reasons
or for you know workloads that have
existed for 10 or 20 years
we preserve the default behavior for the
default service account which does use
those restricted access scopes as a way
to do acls
makes sense okay so moving on to our
next question and this is from guillaume
b
who asks
when should i use the service account
key file or when can i avoid it on-prem
locally on gcp so seth can you answer
this one for us
yeah this is a really funny question
because hume and i have actually talked
about this
you know offline at length
real quick i do want to clarify what
guillaume is asking is about a service
account key which is different than a
service account so carter already gave a
really good explanation of a service
account it's basically a robot that can
authenticate like a human
as a human you tend to authenticate with
like a password well
a service account doesn't have a
password it's usually just an email
address so the way that you you know
i'll use air quotes login as a service
account is with the service account key
it's basically the password and anyone
who has that key can authenticate and
act as that service account
so to directly answer the question when
should i use the service account key the
answer is never
you should use service account keys as
infrequently as possible because you
convert an identity management problem
into a secrets management problem where
are you going to put the key how are you
going to rotate it how are you going to
audit access to it what happens if it
gets in the hands of an unauthorized
party
so
in general you should use service
accounts or service account
impersonation as much as possible so
let's say you're working locally whether
you're building an application or you're
running something like terraform you
should authenticate with gcloud or the
cloud sdk when you do this your local
human authentication credentials will
automatically be picked up by those
tools
similarly if you're using any client
library that google publishes or any sdk
we'll automatically use what are called
default application credentials to pull
the credentials from your local machine
if you're running on google cloud
cloud run gce kubernetes whatever you
can use the machine identity or the
workload identity to attach a service
account specifically to the workload so
for cloud run or gce you pick which
service account you want to use when you
spin up the service or the vm
for say kubernetes you actually use
workload identity to map the kubernetes
service account to a gcp service account
in all of these situations you're still
using service accounts but there's no
key exchange we're relying on google
cloud to provide the identity to the
service specifically the metadata
service if you want to get into some
detail
but then you might ask yourself well
what if i'm multi-cloud what if i'm
running on another cloud provider how do
i authenticate then well
if you're running on say aws or azure
you can use workload identity federation
or wif as i like to call it to
basically delegate trust you can
use information from say that other
cloud provider and present that as an
attestation to google cloud and assuming
that you've configured it to allow that
attestation you can exchange say your
aws credential for a gcp credential
again never actually exporting a json
service account key
so that really leaves the like
on-premise scenario where you don't have
an identity provider like active
directory
or your you know you have some
collection of desperate systems
this is really the only situation in
which you would need to export a service
account key um where you don't have what
we call an idp or an identity provider
that is oidc compliant in those
situations unfortunately today the only
option is to export a service account
key but in general especially you know
working locally on your laptop or
anything that you run on google cloud
you should be able to do so without
exporting a json service account key and
in fact
if you work for you know a large
enterprise your company might have an
organization policy that prevents you
from downloading those service account
keys which we can talk about more maybe
in a future episode on org policies uh
because that's at least a 30-minute
episode all on its own
yeah this can branch out all sorts of
directions but to sum it up as you said
so so best practices use attached
service accounts whenever possible or
workload identity to attach service
accounts to kubernetes pods or you said
whiff workload identity federation to
let applications running on premise or
other clouds to use a service account
and
if you you know using service account
keys if there's no viable alternative so
only when it's sort of the last possible
scenario
all right so let's go ahead and move on
to the next question and this is from
eton 2007 who asks
how do you guard against one or more
rogue employees and this is talking
about at one of google's data centers so
carter let's go to you for this tough
question
for this tough one if there's a gaggle
of rogue googlers what do we do uh thank
you at in
207 2007 for this one um
this there's really a lot of different
ways to that this happens seth and
stephanie already talked about this but
google has this thing called
defense and death there's a lot of
different measures in place
so some of those measures are
limiting who has access to what so
example and i think i saw this in
stephanie's amazing data center video
which if you haven't checked it out go
go see it it's amazing but less than one
percent of googlers have access to the
data center so i don't know where the
data centers are i couldn't go log into
one right now so that takes me out of
the picture um two there's a lot of
training and policies on who can access
what and when like when is it okay to
access data and so we get a lot of
training on that and then stephanie
mentioned earlier about how you can pair
something you have with something you
know with something you are and these
are examples of defense and death and
this applies at the data center too so
there's scanners to say hmm who are you
should you be here and if you shouldn't
you can't supposedly get access to
what's inside the data center
so there's a lot of different ways and a
lot of different defense measures that
google has in place to protect the data
centers and i think stephanie can go
into a lot more detail here because you
made this amazing video about all this
yeah uh well actually seth do you want
to do you want to cover it first
yeah so i'll let you talk about the data
center since you're far more
knowledgeable there i'll talk a little
bit about maybe google's internal
controls that we have um so you know one
of the things that you always worry
about is like one employee going off and
downloading a whole bunch of data or
looking at things that they shouldn't
look at and internally at google we have
a number of controls and systems in
place that
enforce kind of three things they
enforce your authentication so are you
are who you say you are we already
talked about context or access we have
uh custom built hardware for doing
multi-factor authentication using
security keys so let's just say that's
kind of a you know a solved problem
then we have uh do you have cause for
accessing this data so
googlers can't just go look at data
there needs to be probable cause kind of
like in a courtroom almost that cause
could be a customer support ticket uh it
could be a production outage there's a
there's a number of safeguards there's
maybe like 20 of them but whenever i'm
trying to access user data or any
googlers trying to access user data they
have to provide some justification um
and that justification uh again can come
from a number of other sources it could
be customer initiated or it could be
from an outage and then the third piece
of information they have to provide or
go through is usually some multi-party
approval so even if there's a support
case
in order to go look at the user data
they would need someone else on their
team or their sister sre team to approve
that request that request is time
limited they may only have that
authorization for say 30 minutes or an
hour until they need to renew that
authorization so multi-party approvals
and justifications
and then an underlying audit log that
tracks all of this so you know even if
someone goes through all the processes
of approvals there's still an audit log
under the hood that demonstrates the
steps they took who approved it what
tickets or tickets was it attached to um
and then ultimately that can get
surfaced in our access transparency
report which is a google cloud product
where you can see if a googler has
access to your data why they accessed it
and what approvals they went through to
do so
yeah it's all about reducing insider
risk through automation doing things in
a very safe and controlled way with the
two-party approvals and the limited apis
so we that we don't expose any sensitive
information um but yeah same thing goes
for uh google employees access to any
end user information through access
transparency as you mentioned so there's
there's a security white paper that you
all should check out um lots of stuff
that seth has worked on as well but to
just touch on the data center experience
that i have i can tell you from
experience you know it was very
difficult for me to even be able to be
in there in the first place but you know
acls are important so you have to be on
an access control list to even be
authorized to enter there's as i said
the badge readers everywhere um there's
biometric scanning at certain locations
in the data center in particular
especially the data center floor so
lots of measures in place to prevent
rogue employees as well as uh you know
from anyone trying to leave the data
center by bringing anything out there's
metal detectors as you as you leave
certain areas as well
so and if i could just chime in real
fast like yeah
we don't just do those things for
insider risk as well so like
i know it sounds a little bit brothery
but i wanted to add like an additional
color on like why this infrastructure
exists it and we'll probably get to this
a little bit later but like if there was
ever say a fire at a data center it's
really important that google's global
security team knows who is in that data
center so that we can ensure that
everyone was evacuated safely the same
goes for say a physical building if
there was a natural disaster like an
earthquake we need to make sure that all
of those googlers are safe and accounted
for so it's not purely about preventing
insider risk that's obviously one of the
benefits but this data exists for a
number of internal systems a lot of
which are designed to help keep googlers
safe
absolutely that's important to underline
as well and i'll talk a little bit more
about that in just a moment but we do
have a related question uh and this is
from david adams who asks i wonder if
all data centers have the identical six
layers of security or if this is just
your flagship data center uh this is
probably a question from the video that
i had created about the six layers and
this is related to also the concept of
defense and depth so i'm gonna go ahead
and actually answer
this one but yes all of our data centers
do have and follow the same layered
approach of security at this time
so if you watch the video which you can
check out at bitly
six layers deep you'll learn that layers
become progressively more protected with
access checks as you move to the core of
the data center so you have layer 1
which is the exterior the security
perimeter the property boundaries and
then layer 2 is the main entrance gate
so that has a vehicle crash barrier
fences with motion detection guard
kiosks thermal cameras layer is building
access with the general office area
where hardware and operations teamwork
it actually looks just like a regular
google office in this section too
but it also includes an isolated loading
dock area where secure shipments are
made from vendors that we have already
approved
layer 4 inside the data center itself it
includes operational rooms like the core
network room and the security operations
center now this is very related to what
seth was just mentioning the sock
contains a highly trained staff that
monitors all aspects of security and and
they're responsible for keeping a level
head at all times for example during
these uh major events or if there's a
natural disaster to keep people safe
layer 5 is the data center floor and
that includes multi-factor
authentication like badge readers
biometric scans etc
it's the most protected area and it also
includes layer 6 which is inside and
that's disk erase so once again go ahead
and check out the video to get a full
experience of what it was like to go
through that
all right so moving on our next question
is actually a question we have received
from a lot of our viewers of our
security content on youtube and that is
why do why does google destroy hard
drives at its data centers instead of
overwriting them now i just talked about
disk race which is layer six uh but
let's start with you carter for this
popular question oh i love it cause this
is a question i've seen even on like
series i've made
um and i think to answer this i wanna
first touch back to some of the things
we've talked about here uh google is
constantly taking multiple steps to to
secure our data
and this is the same kind of thing so
if someone were to take a drive that
data is encrypted sometimes it's
hardware encrypted where there's
specific chips on a device to encrypt
and decrypt it but if someone were to
actually have a physical drive they have
something they have an advantage a very
large advantage and that's time and so
they can brute force and they might be
able to figure out ways to to access
that so destroying that is another step
to prevent things like that
and then something i hadn't realized
when i was talking with seth before this
we were running through some of the
questions and whatnot
and he was like yeah well have you
thought about future technology and how
future technology might be able to do
things that we can't right now and so
this is another way to prevent against
that sure um the encryptions might be
very safe now with today's technology
but what about in 20 years and so this
is just another step for ensuring that
our data is safe and secure on google
yeah seth do you have anything to add
there
yeah i'll just draw a quick analogy
because carter kind of explained it
eloquently but i i know people love to
use the word post quantum crypto so i
won't go there what i will say is let's
talk about dna right uh you know dna is
a
an important part of like every criminal
case that you see today but 20 years ago
like no one talked about dna it was all
fingerprint right loops and hooks and
and like fingerprint evidence is still
important but we've made you know pretty
significant advancements in the
biomedical space with respect to dna and
how we can use dna in criminal cases
you can imagine that something similar
will probably happen in 20 years with
respect to data recovery um and that's
you know really one of the reasons why
we're investing so heavily in the space
and why we do like truly shred
physically these hard drives because we
don't want to be in a situation where
someone grabs one of these hard drives
puts it on a shelf for 20 years and then
there's this you know magical new
scanner that you put over and it
extracts all of the data as if it was in
plain text and physically destroying the
drives is is really again part of
defense and depth it's one of the ways
that we can truly prevent that from
happening no matter what advancements
and technologies might exist in the
future
yeah
i think it's also important to note that
we do try to recycle drives and their
components but in the case that a drive
cannot be erased then it is stored
securely until it can be physically
destroyed
and if you're wondering what happens to
this waste we do have researchers in our
oklahoma facility who are looking into
methods of collecting and recycling
these rare earth metals in hard drives
um as you might know data centers are
the largest consumers of these hard hard
drives that contain these elements like
dysprosium and so they have uh these
elements have a major role in components
of like things like electric cars and
wind turbines and so we're doing a lot
there to make better use of them and
there's a great article to check out if
you want to learn more about that
all right so our next question comes
from oliver m who asks
why is there so much physical security
at google data centers and is there any
reason to believe that people might want
to destroy the data or the servers
so seth i'm going to throw this one to
you
yeah so this is a great one um
it's kind of a two-part question so
carter already answered the first part
which is once you have physical access
to a device or a machine or a hard drive
a lot of the bets are off right if i can
run a scan on this hard drive if i can
try to brute force the various
decryption keys if i can you know plug a
thumb drive in um i can do a lot more
damage
to draw an analogy not thinking about
the data center right like if i have a
wi-fi access point in my building um i
can't do much with that access point
if it's up on the ceiling but if i can
get it down on my desk i can like stick
a paperclip into the reset button and i
can reset it i can provision it with my
own custom firmware i can directly
connect to it the threat model changes
the throttle model becomes very
difficult to protect at this point and
we do have protections in place right we
have like secure boot mechanisms and and
the the tpm's that make sure that the
hard drive and the machine hasn't been
tampered with but it's much harder to
protect at that layer
so
that's why physical security is so
important and then to your second
question is like are people trying to
break into google data centers uh i mean
we can't go into a ton of detail but the
answer is not no um and the answer is
not unique to google right
we know that customers store data in
data centers even what we call colo data
centers which are data centers as a
service
much smaller than like a public cloud
provider they have the same levels of
security or similar levels of security
because this data is important
customers are trusting google to secure
their data if we do have a data breach
it erodes the trust that customers have
in securing their data with us so you
know this is why it's so important and
you know
just yesterday and the day before and
the day before that in the past three
days there have been three major
independent security breaches targeting
you know companies that are of the size
of google so it's really not out of the
question that people are trying to gain
access to these data centers and that's
why we have these protections in place
all right well here is another question
that we have received from many of our
viewers
what if a data center catches on fire
would everybody in the world lose their
data so this is one of my favorite
questions that we get so carter can you
help us out with this one i'm gonna play
with that question a little bit uh
if a data center caught on fire would
the world lose all of its data no
because not all the data in the whole
world is stored in one data center but
what about aliens or zombies
okay so this is what about zombie aliens
all bets are off at that point i'm
hiding in a data center if that happens
look um here's the thing we got to watch
for or think about
when it comes to this uh every
organization if you store important
information whether it's in a in a file
in your desk somewhere whether it's on a
computer whether it's in a data center
you have to have a plan for
the unfathomable for disasters for uh
having to recover your data for a
national disaster or what about like a
spy or national disaster just like
floods yes you have to have a plan for
as much as you possibly can and you i
don't think you can plan for everything
but data recovery is one of those things
and redundancy is one of those things so
you know that there's a what about
godzilla all right i'm about to quit
there's a lot that could happen and and
i'm sure everyone here can go into more
uh but one of the things that google
does really well
is they they duplicate data when
necessary they have multiple zones they
have regions so someone um like a
customer can say hey i want to make sure
that my data is
replicated across zones so that if a
zone goes down i can have uh data still
up and online and so that's one of the
things that you have to do when you're
securing your own
information is set up a disaster or data
recovery plan and google has some of
this in place too at the data center
level to help protect you uh but like
seth is and stephanie were saying
there's so many different cases like do
you guys have a little bit more about
how to actually set this up or
or how much of it is google's
responsibility versus how much is the
customer's responsibility yeah and
something that we already talked about
is that the sock the security operations
center of all google data centers are
also designed to roll up to a regional
sock for multi-regional high
availability purposes so you know if an
on-site sock were to be disrupted due to
an event such as a natural disaster or
an emergency building evacuation then
monitoring instantly rolls over to the
regional sock for continuous
uninterrupted monitoring so socks act as
a center for emergency and safety
response in addition to security
responsibilities like seth mentioned
earlier
you know these socks monitor and respond
to alarms at all of our facilities and
are constantly tracking local and global
events that could impact operations at
our data centers so really you can think
of this like high availability for
physical security and that means it's
high availability for logical security
and data protection as well
and then one thing that is cool to
mention is that we do run dozens of
drills a year paying an unannounced
skilled adversaries to try to get past
controls by any means necessary except
for violence and this includes
everything from fake badges to social
engineering fake ups trucks ladder
trucks to get over the fence people
actually hidden in trucks or attempts in
different environments like thick fog
and you know we usually win
after every attempt the main thing is
that we want to run a blameless
postmortem to improve and make the next
attempt even harder and we ensure the
strength of our security controls and
then we iterate controls as needed so
you know this is all about building a
culture of security
yeah and we also have an exercise at
google which we call dirt uh disaster
and recovery testing which affects both
the software security side and the data
center security side where to directly
answer this question like what happens
if there's a fire at a data center we
have in the past completely severed a
connection to a data center to make sure
that our disaster recovery protocols are
in place because yeah you can write
something down you can put it into
google doc you can print it out and put
it in a safe but an untested backup plan
is not a plan so we actually write and
we've we've written multiple white
papers about this where we actually do
some crazy stuff like we'll cut off the
entire mountain view office and all of
our senior executive cell phones and
make them inaccessible and make sure the
organization can continue to function
from a business continuity perspective
but we'll also take an entire data
center you know quote offline by maybe
severing the fiber connection
to make sure that our disaster recovery
plans are in place
all right so our final question of the
day comes from martin w who asks i'd
love to work in a data center so i have
to ask how does one go about getting a
job at a data center so we love this
question seth do you have any tips for
martin
yeah so you can always check out the
google careers page and i think we'll
either drop a link in the comments or uh
we'll show it on the screen here um but
we actually have a lot of openings in
our data centers we also have a lot of
openings for software engineering
positions site reliability engineering
positions um the only one that
guarantees you'll see the inside of a
data center is the data center
engineering positions but you should
always check out the google careers page
uh you can filter by location including
remote work
and we're always opening up you know new
new positions and new areas you can also
set up alerts to get an email anytime a
position opens up that fits your custom
filter criteria i so
sorry i just so really want to try and
get a job sneaking into the data centers
like if that's on that page i'm signing
up today
those are usually external firms i
actually used to work for one you won't
find that on my resume or linkedin but
um it's a really fun job but
uh you will occasionally end up in jail
um at least for a night while they get
ahold of the cso or the cio to confirm
your story that you were in fact hired
by the agency that you were
penetrating at the time yeah and i'm
also hosting the second season of where
the internet lives podcast and that's
where we explore more roles like
environment health and safety operations
mechanical engineers data center
technicians and hardware operations
managers so check that out we're going
to be diving into the background of the
people who are employed at data centers
and you'll probably learn about some
roles that you don't even know about yet
um we also are creating this animated
series on our youtube channel here it's
called discovering data centers where we
explore the innovations that exist at
our data centers and how we physically
build our data centers all the way down
to the software stack that makes our
technology built at the data center so
distributed and at scale lastly i do
want to just mention that the career
site is going to be included
in the links here so that you can check
it out and we are always hiring for
roles even internships all over the
world so right now we have open rules in
singapore japan all over the u.s and
chile so be sure to check that out
all right well that's all the time that
we have for today
unfortunately but thank you so much for
everyone joining our ask google cloud
live chat we hope that your questions
got answered we're going to be back with
more live chats throughout the year as a
reminder we'll be featuring your
questions from youtube instagram twitter
so send in your questions using the
hashtag askgooglecloud and comment below
if you have a question that we didn't
get to today so thanks everyone for
watching we'll see you all next time and
seth and carter stay out of trouble
[Music]
you